migration is a divisive subject some of
the biggest upheavals of the past decade
have been partly driven by the fear of
mass migration but some compelling
evidence is often overlooked and it
tells a fascinating story one in 10
migrants flees war or persecution but
the vast majority of them move to
another country to improve their
economic prospects The Economist has
long argued for free movement of people
because the evidence shows that opening
the door makes the world richer
migration is the biggest pre-lunch in
economics at the moment is the simplest
policy change you could make that would
have the most immediate effects in
making the world richer the best
estimate says that the world's GDP would
be roughly double in somewhere between
50 and 150 percent bigger every year if
people were allowed to work where they
wanted that figure is based on a range
of estimates and compiled in a paper by
Michael Clements an economist entitled
trillion dollar bills on the sidewalk
hey Michael it's Asher here in Anna's
she's a director of the film I'm gonna
talk to you thank you the back of the
envelope calculations make it
I think beyond doubts that there are
trillion dollar bills on the sidewalk
it's a tremendous wasted opportunity for
everybody Michael looked at how much
Richard the world would become if we
removed different kinds of existing
policy barriers for example removing all
remaining trade barriers would increase
the world's GDP by up to four percent
but removing all barriers to migration
would increase GDP by between 50 and 150
percent in other words more migration
could make the world spectacularly
richer just one in 20 people who are now
living and working in poorer countries
if 1 in 20 of those people were to work
in richer countries that alone would add
more value to the global economy than
dropping all remaining policy barrier to
trade the same worker in Ghana working
in the United States or the United
Kingdom can see the productivity of
their work go up by a factor of more
than eight there's nothing inherent
about that person that changes when they
get off the plane it's it's being in
this economy where they have access to
other workers other capital other
arrangements of production there are an
estimated 270 million migrants in the
world but another 750 million people
worldwide would migrate if they could it
actually only takes a modest movement of
people to start to have macroeconomic
impact I to the tune of trillions of
dollars if you want to read Michael
Clements is paper as well as The
Economist coverage on migration you can
click on the I at the top right corner
of the screen
when it comes to migration the biggest
beneficiaries are the migrants
themselves Beth works as a domestic
helper in London she was born in the
Philippines she started working at the
age of nine but life was a struggle
so 23 years old I decided to to leave
home I went abroad and I went to the
Emirates to tell my family and to live
up them from the property and it's a
hurt for me to leave them but I need to
sacrifice for them
when Beth moved from the Philippines to
the United Arab Emirates
he immediately earned more money much of
which she sent back to her family but
she was deeply unhappy I cried a lot I
miss my family during that time you earn
money for your family so that's the main
reason why you're there not for pleasure
for work after 13 years in the UAE Beth
managed to move to London she found a
job with a family he sponsored her for a
visa
I'm so happy to reach this prestigious
country I found my employer is very nice
and I'm still working her until now 16
years she now sends even more money back
home which has contributed to her
younger sisters education and paid for
medical treatment for her nephew if you
support them you're so happy you felt
like you're successful
the money that Beth sends back to her
family is known as remittance
remittances are worth over 10 percent of
GDP in 30 countries around the world
including in the Philippines and in some
countries such as Tajikistan and
Kyrgyzstan remittances are of a size
equivalent to almost 1/3 of their GDP in
2019 remittances are expected to become
the largest source of external financing
for developing countries surpassing
foreign direct investment and more than
three times greater than foreign aid the
benefits to the country's migrants come
from go beyond money transfers migration
builds trade ties with developing
countries it transfers technology it
builds investment links if migrants
eventually return they also often bring
with them new skills and expertise some
critics complain that there is a brain
drain from poor to rich countries
Michael Clements says the outflow
actually benefits those poor countries
there is no poor neighborhood poor city
poor region or a poor country on earth
that has ever been shown to have been
developed in any sense by trapping
people there the migrants themselves
clearly benefit as do the countries they
come from but what about the countries
they move to a common perception is that
migrants take jobs from locals undercut
wages and abused welfare in their host
countries i javonni parry is an Italian
born economist who researches the impact
of immigration people have very strong
opinion about immigration without
knowing very well the facts the very
basic facts the evidence is that
immigrants do not compete very directly
with natives in their jobs javonni's
research finds that instead of competing
for the same jobs immigrants to America
largely compliment local workers you
often end up working with them or
managing them
you need engineers you need four manager
you need the sales representative you
need clerks so this is called the
complementarity job job don't come in
one job are connected
when migrants take low-skilled jobs in
rich countries such as looking after
children or sweeping floors
Giovani Perry finds that after
immigrants arrive natives tend to move
into higher skills higher paying work
but what about high skilled migrants
there is even much more of a positive
impact here because they have a very big
impact on in innovation and these
measured as patents as new prod products
as scientific innovation I would say
that is a disproportionate contribution
from foreigners in America immigrants or
their children founded 45 percent of
Fortune 500 companies including Apple
Google and Levi Strauss
despite the well-established benefits of
migration most countries still make it
very difficult to immigrate they do this
because many voters object to
immigration or are frightened of it
immigration is disruptive and it needs
to be managed carefully but the public
perception of migration is often
distorted a study carried out in 2018
asked people in six rich countries to
estimate the percentage of the
population or migrants in America the
average estimate was 36 percent when in
fact migrants made up only 13.5 percent
of the population people in other rich
countries also tended to overestimate
the number of migrants and they also
overestimated the proportion of migrants
who were unemployed which in some
countries such as America is even lower
than the unemployment rate of the people
born there
and these misperceptions about migration
feed directly into government policy
for this reason the odds seemed stacked
against a sudden opening of borders but
as Michael Clemens points out the
changes need not be radical for people
to start enjoying some of the potential
benefits it certainly doesn't mean
global anarchy and no regulation what it
means to me is is better regulation
better lawful pathways for migration
better lawful pathways for the most
profitable and the most productive
investment that's available to most of
the world's poor and that's that's a
tremendous opportunity for humanity as a
whole so how should countries be shaping
their migration policies that's the
subject of another film which takes us
to Australia a country were almost a
third of the population are foreign-born
and the economy has been growing
steadily for 28 years you can find out
more about how the world can learn from
Australia's migration policy by clicking
on the link opposite the other link will
take you to some of our resources
including research data and a special
report by The Economist's foreign editor
as always if you enjoyed watching don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]